Bitcoin moved while you were asleep.
You wake up,
and the number on your screen
is a different number.
So who did that?
There is no central bank here.
No committee sets this price.
And yet something clearly moved it.
Stay to the end
and you will know which forces move Bitcoin in hours,
which move it in years,
and the one number to watch instead.
Twenty-one million coins.
That is all there will ever be.
It was written into the code
before most of them existed.
No committee can raise it.
No emergency can print more.
So where does a price come from?
A price is not a fact about an object.
It is an agreement between two people.
One person willing to sell.
One willing to buy.
Where they meet is the price.
So Bitcoin has two sides,
and only one is up for grabs.
The supply side was settled in the code.
New coins arrive on a schedule
that only ever slows down.
Fifty new coins a block.
Then twenty-five.
Then twelve and a half.
Then six and a quarter.
Now just over three.
Every four years it halves,
and nobody votes on it.
So every argument about the price
is an argument about demand.
Who moves it in hours?
Start with the whales.
A whale is one wallet
holding a thousand bitcoin or more.
Their power is not the size of the pile.
It is that almost none of it is for sale.
Most bitcoin sits in wallets that have not moved in years.
What is on an exchange today
is a sliver of the total.
So the order book is thin -
just a queue of offers
to buy and to sell.
A thin queue moves easily,
and they have names
for how that gets done.
A sell wall.
Spoofing.
A pump and a dump.
But none of that is choosing the price.
It is exploiting how few people are selling.
And who moves it in years?
Developers never touch the price.
They maintain the protocol -
the rules every computer on the network follows.
SegWit, in twenty seventeen,
changed how transactions pack into a block.
It did not move the price that week.
It decides whether the network
is worth anything in ten years.
Governments are the loud ones.
China banned trading and mining in twenty twenty-one,
and the market fell.
The United States approved
spot bitcoin exchange traded funds
in early twenty twenty-four,
and it ran to new highs.
So put the two speeds side by side.
In hours.
A whale's sell order.
A regulator's announcement.
A headline anyone can trade.
Now the ones that work in years.
A change to the protocol.
Legal clarity, or none.
Whether the thing still works.
Nobody is driving
Ask it properly.
Who sets the price of bitcoin
right now, this second?
The biggest whale?
The core developers?
A regulator in Washington?
Or the last person willing to sell?
The price is whatever
the next buyer and the next seller
agree on.
Which is why size is not control.
A whale holding a hundred thousand coins
cannot sell them at today's price.
The moment they start,
it stops being today's price.
There is a plainer way to say it.
The price is set by the last person willing to sell.
So who controls Bitcoin's price?
Nobody does.
Everybody does.
So what should you watch?
Which changes what is worth watching.
Not the whale wallets.
By the time a big transfer shows up,
the trade is already done.
Watch how much bitcoin
is sitting on exchanges instead.
Coins moving onto an exchange
are getting ready to sell.
Coins moving off
are going to sleep.
So - back to the morning
you woke up to a different number.
The question was never who moved it.
It is how few people were left to buy.
Know that,
and it stops looking like a decision,
and starts looking like a room
changing its mind at once.
The full breakdown is linked below,
and nothing here is financial advice.
If that was useful, subscribe.